just found out like two minutes ago that
Lorraine Warren the author of the cases
that some of these conjuring movies are
based on has just passed away so I'm
gonna go ahead and dedicate this episode
of things you missed to Lorraine Warren
and if you want to hear about how liya
Dona sets up for another movie then
stick around to the end of this video
welcome back to things you missed but
first Rance time I know it's become kind
of a horror cliche for a character to
brush off something supernatural by
telling themselves that it was just in
their imagination but the curse of La
Llorona takes this to the most
ridiculous level I've ever seen like
almost every character has ample
opportunity to say hey you know that
thing that just happened that wasn't
normal maybe I should get help maybe I
should make like Andre 3000 and get up
and go to church but they don't it's so
frustrating like those two Alvarez boys
who tell the social worker that she'll
hurt us if they leave the closet why
would they say that and not clarify that
they're talking about a spooky ghost not
their mother who's being investigated
and then the main family is even worse
they each have individual encounters
with La Llorona
but when asked what happens they're like
nope nothing happened nothing mom I gets
because she has to uphold her
credibility because she has a job but
the kids have no reason to hide it and
it's just completely illogical and then
around the midpoint they all encounter a
lot ona together and they basically get
together and decide nope that was
nothing right we didn't see anything but
anyway that was frustrating but let's
move on to the things you missed the
first clue that this is just the
conjuring but with Spanish legends comes
in as soon as we get into the main
setting of the movie Los Angeles 1973 a
long fast moving handheld tracking shot
takes us through the house in the exact
same style the opening of the conjuring
when we first meet Anna's daughter Sam
she's watching an episode of scooby-doo
and this is probably the point where
everybody leaves a comment about me
being Shaggy's brother so I'm gonna go
ahead and use just point 1% of my power
to extract this thing you missed the
episode that she's watching features
someone pretending to be a ghost in
order to terrorize people as many
scooby-doo episodes do at the end of the
curse of Llyod onna we are led to
believe however obvious it might have
been that Llyod onna broke the fire seed
barriers
up at the door and got into the house
when in reality it was actually Patricia
Alvarez the mother who had her two sons
taken by laia Dona
and thought that by sacrificing Ana's
kids she could get hers back
she wears similar clothing and takes off
her shoes to give the appearance of the
ghost just like the villain Emma
scooby-doo episode the actress who plays
Anna also played a Velma in the
live-action scooby-doo movies the scene
where Samantha sees Llyod onna through
the clear umbrella next to the swimming
pool is very reminiscent of a short film
called kam closer in which the
supernatural occurrences only show up
through a cellphone camera I'd like to
believe that that umbrella scene is in
too blatant plagiarism because the
director of camp closer and David at
Sandburg also directed Annabel creation
which is a part of this universe so
maybe they had his blessing to lift the
concept I'd still love to see kam closer
adapted into a feature film in the style
of lights out
but speaking of lights being out and yes
I'm aware that is a terrible transition
during the scene that takes place in the
middle of the night where Ana calls out
asking if someone's in the house as if
the intruder a ghost is just gonna be
like oh you got me April Fool's but Ana
goes back to look into her room and if
you look to the right side of the
doorway you can spot La Llorona standing
there in the corner hiding in the dark
now I was going to point out that father
Perez is the same priest that helped
Samia and John out in Annabelle but the
movie makes it pretty clear when he
explains that he opened up his mind to
things out of the ordinary after an
incident with a doll so I'll point out a
couple of other Annabelle connections
instead misty is the name of the doll
that Sam carries around and nearly kills
them all when she accidentally breaks
the fire seat barrier when trying to
grab the doll from outside it resembles
a Raggedy Ann doll the real-life version
upon which the Annabelle doll is based
on also in my last episode when I talked
about the Annabelle comes home trailer
one of the things I pointed out was this
wedding dress in the Warren's room of
cursed objects now that why you Dona is
confirmed to be part of the conjuring
universe I think it's very likely that
this is why you don't dress ana is after
all able to cook like the Sapphire
locket off of her when trying to banish
her from the house so it stands to
reason that by fully defeating the
weeping woman ed and Lorraine could at
some point obtain this dress it is
hinted at that she survives at the end
of the movie based on the final shot
where Ana looks back and sees something
in the reflection of the puddle which is
consistent with the numerous occasions
of why
appearing in mirrors and causing them to
break but does this mean that we're
going to see a Wyatt on that dose well I
have a better suggestion the conjuring
and the conjuring to both open with Ed
and Lorraine Warren on a case that's
unrelated to the main case of the movie
the director of the curse of ye Dona was
Michael Chavez who's also supposed to
direct the conjuring three father Peres
tells Anna that the church has people
who can deal with evil spirits but it
takes several weeks for these things to
be approved by the church we see the
same thing happen in the conjuring where
the exorcism isn't approved until after
it's already over the Vatican approved
the exorcism so my idea is that father
Peres puts in the request for Anna
anyways in the opening of the conjuring
three or really any conjuring movie
shows liya Dona being defeated and her
spirit being locked inside of the
wedding dress which is kept safely in ed
Warren's home as far as further
connections go the shaman Raphael who
helps out the family explains that he no
longer works with the church and he made
it seem like there's some history there
so I wouldn't be too surprised to see
more of his story in another movie the
next one is a bit of a spoiler if you
haven't seen the conjuring 2 but I mean
I think we all know what happens when
they finally do banish liya Dona by
stabbing her with the cross she
disappears in a manner that looks almost
exactly like the defeat of alec at the
end of the conjuring - rola rain
banishes the demon back to hell so it
seems that neither one of these entities
is gone for good I'm gonna be doing a
little mini marathon or I'll be covering
all three Annabelle movies here on
things you missed so remember to
subscribe to seize these world for new
Horrors every week bring the death bell
or notifications and I'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]